the Makoto chooses its owner but he who
had the self-delusion should at once be
warned the Makoto is no sword for the
faint of heart many stories have been
told about a cursed weapon forged for a
giant in a distant land some call it the
Makoto a cursed katana the chaos blade
it is said that where the blade meets
skin it will tear apart into a wound
that will never heal it is a cursed
weapon that devours the wielders life
energy eroding the wielder along with
his enemies yet despite this warriors
continued to search for the treasured
blade hoping for it to simply pass down
through their hands hoping they can hold
on to it longer than the one who came
before them
is it not so that thou art new thou
fared well to find me
I'm Alvina of the dark route would I
command a clan of hunters who tracked
down two filers of the forest graves
what does thou say well they're not join
us oh yes I believe we would suit thee
well the forest hunters protect the
graves of the forest we follow Alvina
without question and reap rewards from
the grave robbers who trespass hunt and
kill as you like whoever is fastest gets
the prey
you
I've heard all about you i'm shiva of
the east captain of the brigade ah did
you notice that one sharp eyes he's fond
of the clan from the east like myself
always slinking in the shadows but he is
a tough one you'll see what I mean
ah don't worry is a good old time isn't
it great to have you with us good
hunting to you the hunters are like a
brotherhood except when it comes to the
kill there are little in the way of
rules and the hunters fight for their
own reward
perchance has the met Shiva a lad cometh
from the Far East strong alarm now a
clan leader of ours and yet still I feel
that boy hides something of that I am
certain small fear that he will use us
badly yet on God we must stay most do
not stay long within the forest there
are worse things in Lordran than a few
grave robbers and Alvina knows this
however once you leave the forest
covenant you mustn't return you gained
some skill in the forest and it helps
defend yourself against the hostility of
the world but an adventurer needs a good
weapon most of all since steel can never
betray you
hello again strange to meet away from
the clan and the forest but why you are
here how about some equipment I love
collecting these things
but I can only keep so many and you know
you are a friend I'll sell them cheap
have you heard of chaos blade the
legendary sword of the ancient undead
Master Mikoto its blade a swirling
vortex
I heard is somewhere around here but I
can't find it it's all I could ever wish
you I do anything to have it I feel as
though the blade was originally supposed
to be found past Blighttown hidden
somewhere out of man's destructive reach
deep within izalith untouched by the
demons that spawned when the first flame
was replicated the chosen undead finds
the chaos blade and leaves black town
but you do not go unnoticed why look at
you just wait with you your sword is it
not the chaos blade I've been searching
for her for ages I beg of you
and I promise repay you will you give
the soul to me quite alright I cannot
blame you the blade is yours after all
so I would do the honorable thing and
kill you for it don't you run away be
still you rat taste my blade taste it
you devil what a wonderful specimen like
slicing through butter who'd have
thought I'd be the traitor sometimes you
never know do you
don't you ever come round again the
black ayob is a tool of revenge it leads
you to the painted world where Shiva
hides with his prize have a look at my
sword for it's a lasting you'll see yeah
right colour of blood after defeating
Shiva the blade is yours once again but
perhaps it's better that you leave it
here in a place created for creatures
and things that have no real place in
the outside world lest it be discovered
again
you